you get to linger loves music more than
anything especially her drums for 15
years the 22 year old has been
practicing whenever she can and playing
wherever she goes when I play it's like
climbing up somewhere high but in the
end I find myself still on the ground I
love Ferris wheel to zumba the
percussionist lives in Kinshasa the
capital of the Democratic Republic of
the Congo in Congo drumming is a
predominantly male pursuit so troll Inga
had to learn everything on her own
mostly by watching other musicians play
there was always conflict than her
family for this reason she left the
family home at the age of 19 but I
varsity's at first it was really
difficult it was not easy to get my
family to accept what i'm doing here but
acceptance has come from her family as
well as from the men in the local
drumming scene I suppose your vehicle is
only succeeds in your phone normally i
play with men who get is different from
other women she's just great
what what sit don't not for me it's
amazing not strange but amazing she's an
extraordinary girl Andre yoga is a music
professor at the National Institute of
Arts he sums up the prejudice to linger
faces many believe women should not
touch the drum a sacred object in
Congolese society love from it fit this
the woman is a fetish when you go to war
do not touch women when you go fishing
do not touch women when you go hunting
you must not touch women if you touch
women you lose and so the woman is also
an object of taboo and two objects of
taboo cannot be together but talingharr
does not want to give up her dream she
encourages other women to join her
regularly meeting to play music
spontaneously young people from the area
watch her with interest talingharr is
now well known in Kinshasa but she still
has problems the 22 year old is still
looking for a producer to support her so
far without success but she is
determined one day I'm going to open up
a cultural center to train other artists
tlingit is already a role model for many
girls now she wants to get to the top
and become a big star in Congo